this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by our
supporters on patreon they get every
episode of playwatch listen early
including this episode which was up
there on time and a little bit late for
everybody else just because I had some
internet issues also apologies about
some of the audio in this episode I
think the remote setup just ate itself
but yes if you're a fan of the show and
you'd like to show some support you can
check us out on patreon has anyone been
playing Zelda by any chance
I've not been watching like 15 million
people I've been watching like 10 second
videos of it great okay
uh Curious is there any reason you
haven't played it specifically
just busy just busy and still playing um
Jedi Survivor so that's I'm like a month
behind the disc of course at the moment
I'm on the new I'm on the second train
that starts that game tell me about
Zelda I want to know about it because
I've not actually read many reviews or
seen many videos are you having a great
time with it Alana or
um yes but I
think I'm curious to I need to both play
more and to talk to people about it
because um
it's very big and I'm not a person who's
ever really enjoyed building things like
I'll have fun with Lego if I'm following
a specific instruction guide
um and I can do Minecraft if I make a
really specific plan but the openness of
Tears of the Kingdom didn't appeal to me
as much before it came out
um I'm having a really fun time because
you can get so silly with it but I think
that's because I'm streaming it when I
play it I don't know if I'd enjoy it
that much solo
um
but it's amazing potentially yeah for
sure and I've had a lot of fun watching
what other people are doing with it
because it's like the stuff people are
making like I saw someone made a paddle
boat someone's made a Mech like that
flies with like little robots that was
amazing it's incredible like it's so
where did you land on breath of the
world I really like breath of the wild I
think it's incredible yeah am I I'm
probably being ignorant here breath of
the wild is the same map right so what
makes it feel bigger is it the
verticality is it like the quests and
the structure of it like what are they
what makes it feel so much bigger than
breath of the wild it's vertical it's
verticality both up and down
so it's the same map except that there
are islands in the sky and
um like a cabin underneath the ground
right so it feels massive
um it's like the Elden Ring Thing of yes
like an entire underworld map below yes
you get on that elevator and you're like
oh boy
um yeah it's pretty much that it's uh
I think it's also just
I wasn't a huge fan of the intro
sequence but then I just saw IGN post
yesterday or the day before they were
like
Zelda teaches everybody how to do the
best tutorial and I was like oh like
maybe maybe I have the absolute wrong
read on that because I wasn't a huge fan
of the tutorial I felt like it was like
very
um it's very long it's like a five hour
tutorial page of watching play testers
tells me there everyone has a different
completely different correct way do
tutorial and it's yeah yeah it's just
very it's never been yeah oh that's well
I guess they've got a lot of Concepts to
cover especially for a broader audience
who maybe aren't familiar with like
other kind of crafty games totally and
they do do a really good job of like
giving you the new ability and then
putting you in a shrine that requires
the ability to solve it
um which is probably the best way to do
that
um I think that I expected the game to
give you the new abilities that you have
further apart it's all you get them all
or most of them really early like in the
first 10 hours of what's probably 150
hour experience in the long run
um but yeah otherwise been having a
great time watching Everybody brutally
murder Clorox which I guess is a thing
everybody wanted to do because they
hated them in breath of the wild and I
did not
in
breath of the Wilds you go to has to use
like one of my favorite characters and
the reward for for finding all the
Clorox which can take a really long time
um because a lot of them are hidden you
don't even know where they are
um is like you get a golden pile of poop
and so as a result of sounds like an
American Dad
as a result of that outcome uh I think
people are really just torturing car
rocks and it's been
it's been a ride I was very curious with
Nintendo being as like family friendly
as they are what the meetings would have
been like
where surely they knew humans would have
done that surely they like they knew
that that was gonna probably have the
data yeah like how long did it take for
somebody to make a dick out of a couple
of Boulders and some sticks that
happened real fast like what the
approach to that kind of stuff is for a
company like that but it's all that TTP
was a metric I've encountered before
like yeah it's time to penis yes it's
like there is there is definitely that
is a term Within game development like
you can't really you you there's no way
they could have made a system that was
penis proof no and I'm if they had have
you know like they still censor words
sometimes on Nintendo chats and
usernames and stuff
um if they have it just would have
stifled creativity in such a negative
way like I'm sure but I'm sure that was
a meeting I'm sure that was a meeting
where they were like how much dick
should we allow
and they had to be like all of it I feel
like there must surely be a kind of
Streisand effect to that sort of thing
as well where if you go out of your way
to try to limit it then you encourage
people to find that one obscure loophole
that like engages them
far more than if it's way open-ended
than the like the predictable subset of
the population is going to do their
thing and be largely ignored by
everybody because there's nothing
intrinsically unique or creative yeah
yeah it's boring yeah if you make the
dick interesting everybody wants to see
it
the system had this like if there was
like dick recognition that you know
there was like a million ways that you
could try to like build your world
uh and the system would kind of see
through that and somehow stop you
something about it if you want to figure
out creativity or show creative this is
what we needed
dick detection here's what my here's
what my prediction would be is if if
they had a thing where like on a
two-dimensional surface you know you
like you said the boulders and the
pilistics if that was the thing that you
know something could kind of image
recognize the the sh the outline and
prevent it
well here's what I suspect someone would
find a way to do it please that's the
title of a video please the thumbnail
that's it
that's the thought everywhere you know
those um you know those 3D sculptures
where like they look like nothing until
you come to that perfect like exact
right angle someone would find a way to
do something and that would be the work
you'd have to see the dick from the
right angle is what you're saying yeah I
guarantee you that that would be the how
does monetization work on YouTube videos
how far into the video can you start
saying the Lord dick every five minutes
it's all over the place and the good
news is I don't care because you're
trading money on the show but we do get
demonetized sometimes which is always
fun or it's at least it's usually ads
limited I only have a tend to get
completely demonetized for copyright
content this is definitely the most
problematic YouTube podcast that exists
100 oh for sure yeah it doesn't go
downhill from here no this is it
everyone else Christian
it's just above the board
it's a bunch of Christian is the
Hallmark for monitors like
monetizability it's good Christian
content interesting yeah 100 interesting
um but no I uh I've had um
definitely this this thing that I keep
having that I have with Lego games as
well when playing Zelda that happened to
me as I got older is I overthink puzzles
all the time
um and I do that with Lego games too
where I just overthink the puzzles and
it's something that I'm not sure how to
turn off
um like I'll build something way more
elaborate than I ever needed to to solve
a puzzle or solve a shrine or whatever
because I think it should be harder than
it is and it's like I finished the water
temple as a child I wasn't even 10 and I
did the water temple now I'm like how am
I supposed to do this
like puzzle design the biggest challenge
isn't how do you tell how do you hint to
the player what they should be doing
it's how do you tell the player it's
okay not to do this incredibly obtuse
thing and that's 90 of puzzle design is
is like giving the player permission to
find the easy option but yeah obviously
it's hard as you get older as well
you're smarter obviously so like you're
gonna keep throwing it seems odds though
am I I keep doing [__]
I imagine working uh I imagine working
in the industry and kind of being all
the more fluent in the the sort of
Telltale recurring you know whatever
that vocabulary that sort of collective
term for the vocabulary of the the red
barrels you know all those little things
that we already can identify that
becomes all the more obvious I think
when you're actually in design
discussions I remember I was playing one
game where there was like worn away
edges on like a wall and I was like well
clearly I can climb on that so I was
like jumping at it for like five minutes
for that reason yeah that's exactly
that's that's 100 where I was going with
that is on Jedi survive which is so
platformy in its
sort of main Drive I feel like that game
is is practically a platformer first and
so many cards uh and and for For Better
or Worse it had moments that I thought
it was awesome and moments where I
thought like Jesus is so elaborately
like this is bending over so backwards
to make me do these moves the ones that
have like the wind
there's wind and you have to like you
have to force put this here and then do
a thing and yeah they always remember
picturing the architect going this is
perfect but uh but those those there's a
few times where I I got through one and
then as soon as I got to the top and I
looked back I realized there had been a
way easier way to do it and I had
effectively done a thing that I suspect
wasn't it's not that I chose a harder
way I think that I brute forced
something that's
only barely possible and not really
meant to be possible like through just
really tedious you know back like where
you could kind of push off of a wall and
then sort of jump back to it and do why
do you think we did that rather than
whatever was the intended solution
it's what you just said I somehow got I
I over thought it or I I spotted what I
was sure was the solution and then only
after I solved it did I see the clearly
much easier
path it's a really interesting thing to
design for like I def I'm sure I've
spoken about this before but I have
trouble with some horror games now
because I survival horror is my favorite
genre of video game I love a horror game
but I now have a problem where I can
very easily
uh ruin uh uh something that would be
scary for myself because of level design
I'll be like oh this room has two boxes
somebody's gonna break through that door
and I'm gonna have to hide from them
behind there and that it happens all the
time and then I didn't even realize I
was doing it until I was playing with
somebody who I guess hasn't played quite
as many horror games and still played a
lot of games and I was like oh you don't
notice any of that huh like that sucks
how did I do that and it's a tough one
that you can't necessarily design for
that player in mind because that's a
minority
um but what's the problem with that's
the creative arms race isn't it you're
having it yeah it's all times you know I
was literally gonna make that same
analogy
like what's the problem of Designing to
the minority of of players where if I
design a thing that I know will get you
uh by it must surely also then just take
every other less attenuated player I
think the balance of this specific
instance that I'm talking about where it
was literally it was Evil Within
um I had trouble being scared by that
game because of the level design uh I
did with people within two finally
enough but um
it would be that I think if you removed
those couple of boxes or whatever it
would be too difficult for most players
to evade the enemy so it was probably
something where when they were first
designing it they weren't there and then
they needed to add more obstacles so the
players were able to survive or get out
of that room or that level or whatever
that is 100 how like iteration on most
of the design works is you start off
with these high fleets you know the
player will get this player will get
that and you put in front play testers
and they absolutely don't and you start
putting in those guide rails and those
helps some of my favorite dev interviews
has happened to me sometimes um has been
a puzzle that they were social players
would get and the players didn't so then
they had to like they made like all
lines point in that direction players
still didn't see it they made it Sparkle
players still didn't see it so then they
had to pull in a camera thing like where
where the camera will pan and like zoom
in on what the puzzle is and that's the
only way people got it
um I even had that when I was play
testing Ragnarok and sometimes when you
do that you
like for like a boss fight design or
whatever we'll
effectively do it with the designer uh
so they see you play it but they don't
comment until afterwards and then
they'll ask you questions and there was
something where like someone was like
why didn't you do this and I was like
you know I didn't see it even though it
was something that was super obvious
like a bright color or whatever that you
have to just repeatedly iterate for
players who just tune things out which
is unfortunately extremely common
there's a degree of magical thinking as
well in game design
um I can't remember who someone tweeted
this recently but it's totally true so
much of like GDC design wisdom like
those passed around game developers in
interviews or in lectures or whatever is
bollocks we invented after the fact and
you often get this kind of
self-repeating stuff like I think it was
Prince of Persia sands of time very
vocally talked about how they use
lighting to kind of guide the player
through levels and that's just become
like an accepted piece of wisdom among
game designs of oh we'll use lighting to
kind of direct the player's eye and do
all this
and that stuff can have like a five to
ten percent difference but it's not the
super magic trick that just solves every
problem and and probably wasn't the
reason that worked in in Prince of
Persia stands of time it probably worked
for a billion other reasons you see that
there's this kind of thing sorry wrong
no no you go ahead I cut you off
oh that's cool
um stop fighting
I don't like it was very polite uh the
Tweet recently
that a player made a complaint
um like an audience remember something
isn't working Dev about yellow uh lines
on boxes and stuff
um I think it might have been in
reference to residue before remake of
like why do we still need this like this
is so outdated why do we need these like
yellow bits of tape or yellow lines and
it's the same thing it's just how would
you ever differentiate what you can
interact with and what you can't unless
there's a bright obvious color on it
because you will miss most things the
yellow tape to break a box is super
important
that's a meeting you have super early on
like we've had that on like future
projects we're working on like okay
what's what's the oh we put a yellow on
this are we doing this like what's the
visual cue we're doing that yeah ties
all this together and then when you
don't do that and like I said this is I
feel like this is every mid-level
experience that game designer goes
through this process where they go oh we
don't need to teach the player that the
player is going to Intuit that the
player is going to understand they'll
look for some and every single time they
smash into a brick wall and the game
designers who like grow and become
better accept that and work out ways to
kind of work around that limitation I've
got a lot of brick walls too like I was
thinking recently
um I'm having a conversation with
somebody about this
Diablo uh I'm very interested in the
story for D4 and I was like as a writer
the challenge of writing
when you can't outside of cutscene see
anyone's faces
um it seems like for a game like that
that they've clearly like gone with this
darker grittiest story where they
definitely want you to be engaged with
the story it came across that way in the
beta
um when you can't steal somebody's
attention by showing them facial
expressions because that's not how
Diablo Works writing forcibly has to be
much much briefer like you have to have
and the way the text shows up on screen
as well you have to have less dialogue
so thus much more meaningful dialogue or
you'll just lose people 100 of the time
especially in a game that's very loot
heavy whether it's going to click click
click click to to get things in their
inventory even play is going in with the
intention of experiencing the story are
probably going to ignore it because they
aren't seeing a visual face to engage
with while the story is being told it's
like what a unique challenge that I'm
really excited to see how they tackle in
in D4 because yeah like any human you
talk to you're less engaged if you're
not looking them in the face that still
applies to video game storytelling I
have no idea how the how they're gonna
do it
It's Tricky yeah and I think you have to
do with a bunch of Cubes or whatever
Mike I was gonna say like literally
whenever this argument happens online
someone says Thomas Was Alone I'm not
going to say Thomas
I no I think it's I think but but then
but then your point stands because
Thomas Was Alone
yeah I'm proud of the writing and the
writing's good but it's Danny Wallace's
voice that really pulled like
emotionally that's what you connect with
which is the same kind of things we're
talking about with the face like there's
a human element in the presentation
um but yeah no it's definitely something
we talk about a lot especially like with
because we've done obviously when we're
doing like like we're trauma Identity or
with any of our other visual novels like
you're just reading that text so I have
you you're a captive audience I can
write about how the brittle rain is cold
and interesting I can I can go off on
one I can be Florida but I can't in like
a piece of text you see fly across the
screen when you're playing one of our
more action Focus games like yeah it's
it's all about it's knowing the genre
you're in and knowing kind of what the
audience is actually doing it's why
there's so many great writers who are
brilliant at writing like item
descriptions and telling a story like
look at how dark souls conveys its story
like there's it yeah you're absolutely
right those are the interesting
challenges like where do you and we do
that like Soul Tech conspiracy was was
an exercise and okay how do we do a
story in a solitaire game and actually
it was FMV but then there's also a lot
of story embedded elsewhere in that game
and I think yeah it's yeah I'm I'm drawn
that's one of the reasons we jump genre
is I'm always drawn to like how the [__]
do you tell a story in this genre that's
interesting it's a very exciting part
about video games
the to the point that you made a second
ago about the kind of iteration on how
to guide the player and how to make
things we had a version of that that has
been very interesting on stray gods
where we were writing the songs
before we ever had them in engine and we
could basically just test them by
manually creating audio edits in order
to kind of give a sense of it right just
like place all the bits together in in
Pro Tools or whatever and just see how
it how it plays and test it you know
brute force and then so then what
happens is like okay here's a brand
here's a choice we want the player to
choose one of these three emotional
responses and then over time we refined
things like how long does the player
have to make that choice and what we
discovered was that became one of the
interesting challenges was that in order
for it to feel very seamless the music
has to always kind of flow directly into
the next thing so it sounds like a
musical number and there aren't these
gaps well the Big Challenge became this
is not a game that's there's no puzzle
solving or like difficulty to this but
yet a difficulty an emergent difficulty
of like oh I I you know I just didn't
see that thing that was sparkling or
whatever our version of that kind of
problem was that the moment the decision
tree appears and you have say 10 or
seconds the music keeps going and the
problem is we were initially writing the
songs where it was still very much
feeding you information
the moment your eye goes to okay I have
three things to choose from you're kind
of
can't fully listen to the lyrics and if
the lyrics are super dense and full of
information you're now split trying to
read your response while still taking in
new information which means that it's
like a timer right so you're applying
that pressure very much yeah it was it
was like it was in our mind it was
almost like we had gotten into this trap
where
the the timer could fully run out and in
the nanosecond before
it ran out but where and now you have
fully completed the outgoing information
yeah you can then make an educated
choice on what you want to do next and
so we realized we had to build a kind of
slope in the lyrics so that over the
last 10 seconds they
they were they were often restating the
point or they were or they were kind of
just getting a little less ground up in
the place where you want the player to
go and jump but but done in a song
writing was that a play testing problem
you found or was that like just for you
guys yeah oh absolutely no well but it's
that it was internal way this was this
was years ago this was well before we
were showing it to anyone on the outside
but even just internally as a team
there'd be like the art director or
somebody who hadn't heard the song so
we're writing them we put them in front
and the feedback came back immediately
and blaring lights you know like I I
when I listened to it in isolation I
realized I would make a different Choice
than when I'm having to make it on the
Fly because I was getting new
information right up until the last
second and that you know would have
changed my opinion so it it required us
to you know do some some revision to
address that's really interesting even
then there's still probably a few in
there that like it someone would
be sort of do well to delay it was one
of those yeah anyways it's for a game
that's not hard or that has zero
challenge whatsoever there was a thing
that resembled a stumbling block for
players that we hit on early on that
without the play testing we would never
have how did you decide it would have
occurred to us how long
people would have to make a choice
because when you're playing a song
that's giving them information and then
then you have to transition into another
song and I guess mix between genres
seamlessly somehow
that amount of time is very important
is it the same for every song or did you
yeah that's the goal I can't remember
the exact if it was 10 seconds or 15
seconds it's funny I played it so many
times you know can I count while you
play it at least
yeah well we and we tuned it so much
that I'm I actually can't remember how
long it's lasted but
um it's uh
it's usually about 10 seconds and then
and when we and once we kind of realized
what we were doing you know it took it
took writing a few songs before we
really felt like we kind of had this
worked out we started color coding the
lyrics where we would turn the lyrics
Pink from like from this point forward
in the lyrics we expect the The Hub
Choice Hub to be on screen so that you
had a sense of while you're writing
what the that the players not just
listening but they're reading they're
reading things as a response to what
they're listening to all in real time
and uh that helped visually clock like
okay you know let's really make sure
that if there's something that we think
the distraction of this Hub is going to
take away from it's before that say 10
second window I love hearing about these
kinds of problems because it's stuff
that play has never really think about
like
that I wouldn't think about when playing
that game if you hadn't told me it's
become hugely tested
yeah every player like the game would
have been probably demolished who knows
what will end up happening hopefully
it's not like in reviews and stuff
yeah yeah oh yeah we we had we had great
I mean the tweets and stuff from people
were there like I played this like 28
times in a row and Jesus it keeps
changing I was like you know we couldn't
pay people to write that kind of
responses but you did all of them
um yes I did pay I contacted every
single Twitter user
um but no it was it was um yeah if we
hadn't play tested that and we just kind
of assumed it would work somehow and
just very cluelessly somehow managed to
ship the game that way then I can't
imagine it wouldn't have been a tidal
wave of immediate feedback going this is
[__] frustrating that you know I feel
like I'm being bullied and I don't
really know what's the sort of what I'm
reacting to and like I hate it and and
they would have probably been quite
Justified to feel that way yeah it's
wild like genuinely like the the because
it's illness what you're saying is
Illustrated as well by how quickly a
patch can fix a game like we've had it
on several games where like we had
volume come out which had our
checkpoints system was great and we got
dinged in every review for it and we
took three days I think just to tweak
how that worked put that up and all of
our Steam Reviews right you know shot up
and the noise from that point and you do
kick yourself in that moment like if we
just done that before we sent out the
review Keys you know we would have a
high meta Creator on that game or
whatever yeah that's not one that you
can email about like when I was
reviewing games I sometimes if a game
had a very big flaw
um I would email the publisher and be
like hey
that's the one oh they did that's the
own that's the only time one of our
games we've ever had that reaction it
happens
yeah when everything's very good except
that one thing is when you're like I got
some time there wasn't time we didn't
have the time it was it was it was like
the when we got those messages basically
was so close to releasing plus you know
there's lead times on like console and
stuff and all this stuff it just we
didn't have time how complicated is a
checkpoint system I have no idea
that is that is definitely one of those
how long is a piece of string it depends
it depends on what you're saving
um and weirdly we're working on some
save system stuff internally right now
so I'm watching the programmers have
these exact challenges it basically
really does come down to how much are
you trying to save and how often you're
trying to save it and then you're
dealing with Hardware you're dealing
with um uh platform limitations on that
you're dealing with how often you want
to have the little spinny thing in the
corner that tells people that they're
saving
um yeah it's it comes down to complexity
so with a simple checkpoint system of
like the player is in this position and
these are the values they have in terms
of like their health and the items they
have and everything that stuff's easy
having I would love to know the
complexity of CSA system in something
like the new Zelda where it's like what
are you saving like every time they
checkpoint you're saving potentially
like their inventions they're taking the
stuff they've put together the objects
in the world where all the enemies are
that they have and haven't killed I
think it doesn't save
what you make but I don't remember I'm
actually like I can't wait to get some
of the data on that of like what gets
saved and where and what the limits are
I'm sure people have found that and I
just haven't looked into it because I I
did some digging into some cool
creations and then unfortunately saw
some cool stuff that I was like oh I
didn't want to see that yet um so I had
to stop looking
um but I'm sure there's some really
interesting points about how many things
you can alter hand together because I
don't know
Safe Systems are one of those things
where there are
like what sound what would sound to the
lame and I think some of this is behind
NDA so I'll be I'll be I won't say much
about it but like the limits on like how
much you can save on Console where you
can save it how often you can save like
those things there are lots of
constraints on because basically it's
one of those things where you're
reaching out of the game code into the
API into the actual kind of the back end
of whichever comes to remind the player
you exist as well like it takes them out
yeah there's a whole
but but just technically there's still
like there's there's a lot of
limitations on what you can and can't
save and when you can save it because
that's why they've gotten better
yeah no 100 no it's all and that all
those limitations I'm talking about make
the players experience better like 100
like that's why they're there it's not
it's not the platforms being awful to us
they are absolutely making sure that
your saves are quick and infrequent
enough that they're not annoying and all
this stuff but yeah there is there is a
I have a question uh that's semi-related
to that but when I am playing a game and
it crashes especially if it's like an
unreal game and you get that unreal
splash screen that is asking you to
potentially like send
your crash report
um is that a thing that is coming to you
eventually uh on the dev side are you
getting like some kind of data aggregate
on it we saw this many of this crash
type this many of this crash type are
you able to is that does that how much
does that influence a patching process
where you're you're going oh you use it
massively yeah so there's there's
there's there's
middlewares for this we've looked into
in the past there's because it always
feels like you're screaming into the
wind it's like if my game is not working
it's not like me sending that is going
to fix I think it's more than this no
it's it's helpful it's not one-to-one
it's it's like I'm contributing to the
long term you're voting you're voting
exactly you're not it's not so it's not
an incremental Improvement it's but but
basically problems are solved in order
of how important how many people are
getting run yeah how many what the
frequency is so you're voting basically
every time you do that you're saying
this is an issue it's a real issue and
it affects me and basically the the
developer will get information but they
get it in aggregate so they're not
getting like oh Austin's got a problem
everyone sit down sit down we've got to
work on this it's much more kind of it's
getting tallied can I register to be
like a power user for the investigation
my machine specifically yeah they're a
major game studios who 100 know like
here's the hundreds biggest streamers
like PlayStation handles or whatever
I bet it is I don't know if it is but I
bet it is yeah
um but yeah no you're like and that's
and that's a vote and then that goes in
and they fix it and then well the other
good thing with those systems is they
have your data so they have kind of a
crash report that's not a sentence we
often hear the good news is with that
your gameplay data which they will
legally be able to collect um which
would basically just be the state of the
game when it crashed because games are
constantly talking like what players
don't see is under the hood you've got a
bunch of logging going on basically
where the game is constantly just
writing a diary of so Austin went up to
the edge of this thing and then he did
this and then that's happened and then
that's it and and that I I know everyone
in this room knows what are we doing
past you to the audience like there's
but there is there's this log that's
happening and that's the thing that gets
sent over and yeah I actually think it's
so cool when we do our internal play
tests and mind crashes and the like one
of the engineers will message me and say
would you mind screen sharing really
quick and I can poke through your crash
log or whatever or send me a the text
file and I love watching them go through
and they'll find like online 723 they'll
realize oh it was calling two Textures
in the same place at the same time for
some reason and that made it lose its
mind and it crashed and we can figure
and there's something very Sherlock
holmesian about watching a great
programmer
like that what line of code is where the
pro or that one line of output of like
crash I was talking to someone the other
day
like watching people be like what the
[__] was this exactly but the one thing
I was saying this to someone the other
day the one weirdest skill that you
notice with coders who've been coders
for a while is we're all really good at
estimation not as not like guessing not
like estimation like in a way that would
ever be useful for any real purpose but
basically whether something looks
whether something looks right number
wise does that you know if if uh if if a
dog walked across a park how many steps
would the dog take well it's gonna be
somewhere in the range of X because
that's the big skill when you're looking
at is that you when you're looking at
log it never says like and then Austin
did this they broke this but it might
say you know Austin's character picked
up 200 arrows it's like no there's no
reason that character could pick up 200
arrows there so like there's a skill
with with debugging we're finding these
errors of like what's a reasonable
number what's a reasonable situation
it's a weird life skill because you then
you find yourself using that in
day-to-day life of like I've missed the
bus well reasonably probably there's
there would be there were this distance
from here like you just start estimating
what it's a strange thing it's a huge
thing in QA too that I it's a thing
about whenever conversations about QA
come up it's started to frustrate me is
um you can be good at QA QA doesn't have
to be an entry level position and we
always treat it like oh will you do QA
until you get a real Game Dev job like
no people can be incredible at QA for
that same reason they're very good at
like drawing logical conclusions about
what the cause of the problem and how to
fix the problem it's it it's all done
we've had the same QA person for years
and years and years and it's because she
is just a monster at like like working
out whether something logically makes
sense yeah absolute gift
um I think the um are we are we doing
the rqa's game developers debate again
they are but writers aren't but is that
discourse bumbling up against not yes no
okay um good fun another fun Game Dev
thing that I saw this week was somebody
looked at statistics for how many
players turn on subtitles
um uh can I get Austin guess how many
people do you think turn on subtitles in
in video games
uh
uh it's probably way more than I would
have ever guess like 50 or something
Mike
so I know the Netflix number is like 25
to 30 so I'm gonna guess like 25 30. 95
what 95.
huh isn't that that has to be some like
is that they can't is that I play with
subtitles
it was supposed to be it was a specific
list of games
um that they found the data for uh 95
subtitles is probably the easiest way I
know it's been a big thing in streaming
services I've had to invest a lot in
streaming subtitles on calls everything
but it's a sound mix issue because most
audio now is mixed for beautiful
surround sound Perfection if you're
watching it on any other context which
is where most people are watching stuff
then there is the the voices are usually
too quiet or muffled or whatever so most
people yeah so a lot of people watching
um
that's why I use them in games is
because exactly that like if the guy's
too far away from me it's gonna be too
quiet so I'm gonna miss it yeah um so it
was from Ian Hamilton who's an
accessibility specialist
uh uh it was Sniper Elite five was 95
and so then he shared a couple more
games uh Lego Star Wars Skywalker Saga
95 Assassin's Creed Odyssey 95 [__] our
new dawn 97 Guardians of the Galaxy 97
and then he also said you cannot afford
to have subpar title Presentation or
content don't let them be an
afterthought and that's totally true and
also subtitles are way harder than I
think a lot of people think they are
um they were really careful with that
for uh that was a big thing for the
accessibility team for Ragnarok too is
like make sure that you have several
options for how people want them to be
presented do you want them to have a
high contrast you want them to be
blurred in the background what does it
look like when you're over there those
options the last few years there's a key
detail in what Lada just said which is
accessibility team that should give
people have an idea of how big these
jobs are like that you need like a
focused team doing that yes I'm sorry to
be sudden about it I just realized the
time
I look forward to you shifting to all
these Austin hates accessibility topics
Austin's like it ruins mine I said just
get good
PC Master race all of it yeah I I uh
honestly this whole thing is very
diminutive and um so I leave you to it
all right bye
um I think the thing with having to get
an accessibility team which obviously I
do think everybody should have or at
least Consultants is that you have
people reminding you all the time that
they you need to think about something
because obviously when you're making a
game you're doing it very quickly
decisions are being made very quickly so
if you don't have multiple people being
like how what is this for accessibility
is this is going to be an accessibility
problem probably one in every department
is necessary to to actually be properly
efficient people just aren't going to
think of it um and I think we're getting
there it's getting a lot better actually
I think ubisoft's really consistently
doing a great job with accessibility
of the the AAA Publishers they're doing
a really fantastic job it's it's getting
better across the board Global
accessibility day uh was I think last
week maybe the week before and people
shared some updates I would like really
love to see more Studios announce what
their accessibility options are going to
be ahead of time going forward like a
mini E3 type that's the big one that
people are asking for now isn't it is
that awareness up front which which
makes sense yeah like a purchasing
decision I'll be bringing back the
accessibility Awards next year I didn't
this year because
um ethically it seemed like a bad idea
with Ragnarok
um not just that I knew that it would be
nominated slash probably win but also
that that's the thing that I directly
worked on the most is he like a bad idea
uh so I was like let's just skip this
year so I'll bring it back next year and
I was going to try and reach out to Dev
teams and be like if you have any
accessibility announcements we could
include them in the show and make that a
bigger thing hopefully oh like keelia
basically like have the the reality
shows in amongst the awards that's
really cool yeah I mean in terms of like
yeah like doing the announcements as
well of it that's cool yeah I mean it
would be effort because it's hard to get
people to stay engaged with
accessibility so that's why like the
show has such a a comedy lean to it is
that I try to make it really funny and
entertaining uh so we would probably
want to talk to those teams about making
sure that they try to make so it can't
be a presentation or most people be like
I don't care about this uh which is
unfortunate because if it doesn't
pertain to them I mean I want to reframe
the way we look at accessibility
entirely to be
optimization or customization it should
be a customization because accessibility
people are like well I don't have any
need for more access to this thing
that's the fundamental problem isn't it
with games as a medium is we emphasize
youth so much which is which correlates
obviously with accessibility and the
idea of like people people playing
either think of themselves as young or
actually young and it's the reality is
it's the it's the old thing that lots of
people say of like you're just
temporarily able yes like in terms of
this stuff yeah like it's it's all going
to be useful for you eventually and as
you know as someone of a certain age I'm
starting to realize that on lots of
levels and it's kind of
of a certain age
um it's it's and I think that's that's a
tough message to in games where we're
constantly like showing that you know
whoever the the new famous 20-somethings
who are playing games on Twitch are like
it's a hard message to kind of I think
you're right like going for the comedy
of it going for the humor going for the
kind of and I think the inventiveness as
well like I bet there's marketing teams
out there you know specific game
Publishers and developers who genuinely
like be able to have a really good so
easily I think reframe it as and and
have a good time with it as
customization play however you want
remap whatever buttons you want make
puzzles however you want them because
that's what it is
um when you play a game and you go in
the settings menu you change brightness
technically that's accessibility it's
based on your own Vision it's making
sure it's accessible to you and your
living room with your TV we just uh
haven't framed the word that way I would
like accessibility to eventually just be
part of the menu and have it be
customizing so everyone's like oh I
should look at this I will like this
game more because I could do whatever I
want with it anything I can do that
buttons I'm a fan of we've got better
with that on lots of levels like
individually so like difficulty I think
is better or explaining that now than it
was but like like I think I think
there's also just opening up the
communication and making I think this is
something you're really good at and
obviously you're putting a focus on but
like
making it not feel like a stayed
charitable
um like it's not like I I think those
are very people are very cautious about
their words and about the way they
communicate about this stuff because
they won't you know offend anyone or or
be insulting or rude to the audience and
I think
actually loosening that up making it
more comfortable for people to talk
about as well which which what you're
doing is a big part of I think just
makes that conversation a lot easier and
a lot more straightforward and it makes
people feel more comfortable talking it
still hasn't asked versus them thing and
you're right people like bless people
who are trying not to offend people it's
a very kind thing to do but if you favor
not talking about it that seems worse
like if you're like oh it's just not
what I'm saying that's what I'm saying
is opening the doors kind of helps and
they'll always be [__] on the
internet who want to make it about it no
I think that will be but we can kind of
but we can kind of talk over them but I
think and the more people talking the
the the more the louder the talking over
them is so with both this I think what
you're doing is great thank you I
appreciate that so with this and our
previous conversation in mind what's the
solution to to aging players
dramatically overthinking the difficulty
of puzzles I don't know what that design
meeting looks like and I suspect that
the answer most people come up with when
talking about this is we just let them
overthink it because I don't know that
there's been a game that's tackled that
and if they have they've done it so well
that you can't tell
I think so I think that these the the
design I think there's a design solution
and I think there's a trend that's going
to continue so the design solution right
now I think it's all about when I'm
designing puzzle stuff when I'm
you know working with my team on these
kind of problems it's about defining the
play space I don't mean physically but
you know from a design perspective what
are the verbs the player has how do we
communicate to them which verbs we want
them to use without being so explicit
that it removes creativity
they need to think there's more than one
option I would think for at least for
tears of the Kingdom you would need to
think there's multiple options and and
that's the so that's the next layer so I
would say the design solution I just
said is for like Puzzles where there
isn't where it's like a Resident Evil
style puzzle back in the day whereas I
know you have to move all the things
exactly if someone's failing and
overthinking that that's a design
problem 100 that's a design problem in
terms of the overthinking I think I
think I think um new Zelda kind of is a
part of this trend I genuinely think we
may look back in a decade
on like the strict kind of puzzle design
as something that was like
that's now massively outdated I think I
think it's one of those things where
basically creating interesting
challenges and then giving the player
the tools to figure out their own
solution to that challenge I think is
has always been something we're moving
towards as an industry and I think right
now we're too close to it that we can't
see that transition necessarily but if
you look at like games from 10 20 years
ago there were much more here's what the
workout what the designer was thinking
and I feel like on the whole we're
broadly moving away from that either
with kind of puzzle games that are about
kind of Creative Solutions like uh
figuring out like your own there's a
million ways of doing it you just have
to be clever enough to come up with on
them or in the case of a lot of like AAA
stuff like just removing puzzles
altogether like it's just it's just not
going to be a part of the the
conversation with our game I feel like
the kind of the find the right answer
style puzzle design I think is going to
go out continue to go out of fashion to
the extent where it feels very
old-fashioned you know in a decade or so
I guess it it is pretty
restrictive and I'll always say the
coolest thing about video games
is the fact that someone's playing it
like as cheesy as that is that's the
coolest part is that somebody is
controlling that world right like
they're doing everything and
realistically the the
taking advantage of the medium and not
just being like let's put a puzzle in
there so that they're not board option
is probably more flexibility in puzzle
design
um which yeah Zelda is doing a great job
of like it's the only game I can think
of
maybe Outsider sometimes in Minecraft
where when I've solved something I am
laughing at
the insane thing that worked and being
like Oh I wonder will this be a weight
problem is this gonna work oh I'm just
being fascinated by how the physics work
and how good their physics system is
like it's it makes it delightful because
you feel like you have ownership of
everything you're doing I think Elven
ring similarly people really like
because giving you that big open World
um in a from soft game and being like
figure it out kid makes you feel like a
genius when you figure anything out even
though it was all there and all put
there and obviously games are designed
to be finished it just makes you feel so
smart
um I think I feel kind of similarly
about games like the witness where
there's no order in the way you have to
solve puzzles and no tutorial it's just
figure it out have fun and then it just
makes you feel so smart when you
actually figure it out and I think that
that I think that's where we're going
yeah and I think I think I think I think
with
um
even with some of the witnesses
definitely like right answers I think
we're gonna move around I think we're
moving we're moving towards
um we're moving towards giving the
player a goal and some tools to get
there and I think that's eventual I
think either we're going to end up with
I think we'll have both we'll probably
continue down the path with like your
AAA kind of
um with apology Sony first party kind of
design school of like I call them
blockbusters
Razzmatazz basically like just let's
make it an amazing beautiful story
beautiful world whatever but kind of
keep you on a relatively confined track
and then we're also going to go down the
kind of Zelda kind of make your own fun
kind of road I I think that's and that
arguably you know it's nothing new
Minecraft was doing it you know a decade
ago but I think I think the audience if
you look at what people are playing it
tends to it's it's going down those pods
rather than the here's what I had in
mind go work out what I the cleverest
level designer in the world have come up
with I mean fortnite that's was that
they were like what if you can make your
own defenses and then people just
started building crazy stuff I always
feel like everyone's a Creator yeah I
mean in Roblox you literally
designing your own games I really don't
know enough about it for how much money
it makes and how popular it is like I'm
like I should just play Roblox and stuff
not one of us do that's the problem like
this that I've met whenever I meet
anyone from the Roblox team it's always
this thing of I know that basically your
your game is bigger than the industry
I'm in you know it's its own industry
Roblox has its own games industry it's
they make so much money for something
that none of us talk about I have one
friend
uh who is a Roblox YouTuber and I had
messaged him before and I was like could
you just one day just teach me what
Roblox is because I just feel like I'm
missing out I get Minecraft and I get
fortnite I don't know what the [__]
going on with Roblox like this is this
is the circle of life it's true it's
fine but I think it's this is why we're
on the drop down for advertising on the
drop down we're still there for another
you're still there
bracket but no I like yeah I I think
that's the that's where I think it's
going and I think I think that's
exciting and I but I also think that
that you know is is something that that
I try and think about when I'm designing
games now I'm not trying to come up with
so like volume for example because I
mentioned it earlier was very much there
were part there were puzzles in that
game where you had to just work out what
I there's lots of puzzles in that game
where you had to just work out the
winning strategy and do it and
definitely now when we're talking about
our games we're talking about like
playing pieces we're talking about Lego
sets we're not necessarily talking about
literally like creating objects or doing
that but in terms of how mechanics come
together in terms of how sandboxes come
together like it's it's how that stuff
we're not going oh well we know the
player is going to do XYZ here it's more
this is a situation we're going to put
the player in and then there's a few
different ways they can kind of deal
with us so hard to play test for
go and check
one of the early puzzles in tears of the
kingdom is
you have a minecart and you have a
railing it's just like two like like a
railroad
um and it goes over and connects two
mountains so it's just two pieces of
railing nothing underneath and the one
on the right is broken
so if you just put the minecart on it
and you make something push it it will
fall off
um the different ways people solved that
I think I might have seen 10. there were
probably four that I could have been
like you could probably do this you'd
probably do this you'd probably do this
the most obvious one is there's like a
hook nearby and you can put it on top of
the Mine card and then you can sit in it
and you'd put it just over the left
railing with the hook on top so it's
like dangling down
but the amount of different things
people did to get through that I saw
somebody make a train so they got
several Minecarts together
um that one I was like well that makes
sense but there were so many of them
that I was like I never even would have
considered that that was possible and
that's the baffling thing right that the
the Nintendo like it's easy to make a
physics engine it's easy like relatively
relatively easy to make a piece
extension but making one that can
withstand
so much and not like crap out most
physics in games like you know you can
bug out very easily I think
it's I just had a bug I just says
physics bugs I don't think that like I
just had a bug and I don't think they
have any physics bugs
that it's like they're so this does it
has bugs and frame rate drops um it has
problems in other places but the physics
like I've not seen a single thing not
that's impressive operate correct and to
be fair that's how you play test a game
like this is It's they probably if they
knew there were lots of solutions things
I'm sure they play tested the whole game
through and and checked to see that like
the the people weren't getting
particularly stuck in any one thing and
people find their own but there was
probably a lot of of player testing just
to see what people tried just to try and
get inside the heads of how people move
generally like I wonder if they've seen
well no they must have seen solutions
that they didn't even try
and then those probably created physics
bugs and then that's where your QA
process comes in and kind of finds those
it's it's a fascinating one it's
definitely on my list of games to like
in a bar with some folks from Nintendo
at some point just like okay how the
hell like did you actually get that it's
very impressive this I think I saw
someone quoting who was it someone seen
you on the on the team who was saying
like they finished the game a year ago
this was a year of like just polishing
QA just to get things as Tiny as there I
believe that like I believe that you
would have to do that with a game like
this
yeah it's very cool
um I already feel like we've gotten some
pretty cool games this year and
obviously a new Zelda game is always a
blockbuster I think it's 95 on
Metacritic highest reviews on the game
of all time
um
they're gonna have to work out more
numbers yeah I don't think you can give
Zelda not attend like it's all I think I
said that for a camera of course I will
um sure which is so interesting
especially for a franchise that's both
so formative for so many other games had
such an impact on the industry and on so
many Developers
but at the same time
is has transformed in of its own
franchise like it's it's both formative
for everybody
um and there's all these gamedev memes
right now of people being like the when
you enter a meeting on Monday and
everyone's like so I've been playing
Zelda and then they just pitch ideas
um it's still doing that like there's a
fresh one that's just come out that did
not stick to the structure that it
easily could have that they invented
forever ago and is still generating
ideas with an entirely different team
obviously same leadership literally same
director but otherwise you'd have to
think most people who worked on early
Zelda have moved on or died it's it's
yeah it's super impressive I wonder if
they have just like an incredible design
ethos or like a manual of some kind or
like something that's that's kept the
quality so high I mean Nintendo in
general just has incredible they do
their first party games approaches and
and they're fascinating when you have
like work conversations with them
because obviously we've done some stuff
with tender over the years and like when
they when they play builds or when they
check stuff out like Nintendo feedback
is insanely good like it's surprised
like it's in depth like it's definitely
in depth but like it's just they're
they're yeah they they they genuinely
think about game design at a level that
I just don't think any of the rest of us
do like it's just it's it's incredible
to me I wonder how that happened it's
it's super interesting
a lot I mean a lot of it um is our
friend Oscar water
um the water back in the day like and
and you know and you know so there's so
there's a whole there's a whole culture
that was established at Nintendo of
humility in the face of the enormity of
game design and it's it's it's it's it's
a very respectful approach to like the
field that they they're Geniuses because
they don't think of themselves as
Geniuses I think I think that's a big
part of it sure there's a an awe and
wonder towards the stuff which I think
also shines through in the games there
is all the Nintendo games have that kind
of
uh or for the awful the franchise for
the for the concept of games like this
just it feels like they're constantly
rediscovering them along with you I
think Pokemon's in a tough spot
um where the last few Pokemon releases
have been
both buggy I mean uh scarlet and violet
definitely the buggiest first party
Nintendo games I've ever played
um buggy and and just poor graphical
performance
um which is an odd one because I know
it's like Pokemon's the highest grossing
franchise I've ever ever of all time
higher than Star Wars uh it's it's
incredible uh I think it's maybe just
the team at game freak is a little bit
too small
um and they release multiple games a
year and I think it's only like 100
people
um and I'd love to see that change the
same token it doesn't necessarily need
to change because they keep selling so
well which sucks uh but I feel like when
it comes to Mario and Zelda
I do not remember the last time I saw a
bug in either of those franchises which
is so so nuts especially because they've
been around for so long it's my whole
life and they're still I think it's
outselling everyone
they also I think they're very good at
innovating in the right areas in terms
of like you don't get the sense that
Nintendo first party are like
you know they're not pushing for like
graphical Fidelity or World Nintendo is
very Innovative though I definitely
think they care about that yeah but
that's what I'm saying is they're
Innovative in the right areas they're
Innovative in the in the gameplay
they're Innovative in the areas that
make creativity sense from but and
creativity is relatively cheap from a QA
process like that's the thing that I'm
pointing out like I think they you can
you can maintain stability and high
quality of product
with with big swings creatively if
you're not trying to do all those other
things as well I think they've found
that right balance um yeah it's their
yeah they're it's it's resourcefulness I
guess resourcefulness I think probably
works very well for tears of their
Kingdom because I don't think they would
have had a lot of scope issues with that
game
um they build the physics engine
they figure out the abilities and a lot
of the abilities came through actually
they were debug modes
um that they were like what if we didn't
make that debug what if we just made
that an ability
uh Ascend was definitely a debug which
basically just lets you it's such a
weird point of the ceiling right yeah
you can just go through any ceiling
um again
seriously look at photo mode like debug
tools have become of such an amazing
source for good game design
yeah well polish scores his scope on
those but yeah but right it's polish
right which is its own yes which is
still less less of a scope problem like
I feel like tears of the Kingdom it's
this is just guessing and I'd have to
think about this harder
um probably didn't face a ton of scope
issues outside of how many shrines do we
have
or how big I think as well like
you might be you might be you might be
really on something with this because
there's there's I mean you're on to many
obviously you're always on to it but I
think this particular I think I think
you're very welcome
um but I think I think like
there's a there's a thing a really good
programmer I've worked with
um one of the best programs I've ever
worked with or basically his kind of
Mantra was that the game designers work
for the player and I work for the game
designers and it was kind of basically
like I'm here I'm not making this code
for the player I'm making this code to
make the designer able to make the
experience they're making for the for
the player sure and I think and I think
and and with him as well that kind of
played into like the tools he created
internally and the the way he kind of
empowered the designers around him and I
think what you're saying here with like
you know the use of debug tools and
stuff like the tools debug tools the
tools designers use they are obviously
the people who've played the game the
most they're playing for thousands of
hours while making stuff and working on
it so looking to what they need and what
they're using and what makes their
experience playful and joyful with the
game world and going is there something
here we can hand to the player that's
it's a very natural and smart it's very
smart that's a clever idea that's a good
idea
before like I'd be interested to do some
research into how many things that were
just debug tools that ended up becoming
mechanics like you said photo mode is
obviously a great one
yeah definitely god mode I just found
out tunic again I finished that game I
did the final puzzle it's one of the
goddamn best gaming experiences of my
life this is the first time in a really
long time that when I finished something
I went and watched a bunch of YouTube
videos just because I wanted to hear
other people gush about tunic
uh after finishing it I found out
like tweeted about it that there's one
more puzzle that I hadn't done because I
didn't even know it existed that is the
hardest thing on the planet I think
maybe I'll try it I'm like I don't I
don't want to cheat it it would be
pointless I have to try it um it's like
hidden in this room that I only went in
one time and it only reveals itself in
that room after you have a certain
amount of things and I only had two
whatever
um the other one is that it has God mode
some of those boss fights I was stuck on
for forever like the final boss fight
which is optional but I wanted to do it
I think it took me like three months of
picking it up and putting it back down
because it's so hard a lot of people say
they bounce off that game because it's
really difficult like the boss fights
are really really hard
um so they stop playing
now you can be like just go God mode
apparently that was in the settings the
whole time and I just had no [__]
ideas
I'm kind of glad I didn't because again
I think they're all really well designed
as well as some of my favorite boss
fights but it's like damn I could have
just not done that you could have
customized the experience
son of a [__] I have to get back to
work
which is a weird thing to do when it's
dark out but here we are oh you still
you're still working us timeline yeah
whole time so it's like my last meeting
ends at 2AM I think
yeah making it worked I'm not from the
other side I'm happy to be able to to do
it at all like I prefer to
not have to skip work and be able to go
places then
yeah it's it's awesome but it is very
weird to be working until 2AM but here I
am uh all right I'm alone you're an
indie developer now look at me go uh
That's Mike bithle he's a video game
director I have a video game writer
Austin was here he's a video game
composer had to go to a composing
meeting probably I don't know probably
talking about should I play or should I
play dude I think that's what most
people yeah yeah he has most of his
meetings we take them for him from now
on to be honest
all right we'll see you guys next time
bye